civil rights hero John Lewis passes away
the media confidently explained that the
United States has failed at fighting
coronavirus it's not quite that simple
and the media continued to ignore
Chinese Genocide I'm pencha Pierrot this
is the Ben Shapiro show the Ben Shapiro
show is sponsored by expressive VPN surf
the web with peace of mind sign up right
now and express it VPN calm slash a bet
we're gonna get to all the news in just
one second and much news there is but
first I told you back in January you
might want to think about that
versifying into precious metals was that
right mm-hmm
was I I was because that was back when
gold was below fifteen hundred bucks
today gold is up over eighteen hundred
why well gold and silver thrive in
uncertain times and this has been a
little bit uncertain right between
coronavirus and the upcoming election
and all the chaos in our streets seems
like a lot more uncertainty than usual
this would be a great time still to
diversify into precious metals listen I
have some gold in my portfolio I think
you should too I trust Birch gold
they've an A+ rating with the Better
Business Bureau countless five-star
reviews even talk to them have them help
you safeguard your investments they are
knowledgeable and they want to help you
preserve your savings you should ask all
your questions you should feel fully
informed before you invest and then when
you're ready to adverse fight and the
precious metals go ahead and talk to my
friends over at Birch gold if you
haven't reached out to Birch gold to
diversify part of your IRA or 401k into
a precious of metals IRA or just
purchase physical gold or silver from
them talk with them today text Ben - 47
47 47 get a free information kit on
protecting your savings with gold again
text Ben - 47 47 47 when you open an IRA
and precious metals before July 31st you
get a signed copy of my last book the
right side of history for free again
it's X been - 47 47 47 right now okay so
the big news over the weekend is that
tragically Congressman John Lewis passed
away at the age of 80 they don't have to
agree with all of John Lewis's
priorities his legislature to recognize
that he was indeed an American Hero that
his role during the civil rights
movement as living man who spoke at the
Martin Luther King March on Washington
his role in the civil rights movement as
an activist fighting for racial equality
and for the rights of black Americans is
unquestioned and good obviously the lake
congressman's family announced his eff
with inconsolable grief and enduring
sadness late Friday evening according to
a statement from NBC News according to
the statement he was honored and
respected as the conscience of US
Congress and an
icon of American history but we knew him
as a loving father and brother who's a
stalwart champion in the ongoing
struggle to demand respect for the
dignity and worth of every human being
he dedicated his entire life to
non-violent activism and was an
outspoken advocate and struggle for
equal justice in America the son of
sharecroppers Lewis was drawn to the
civil rights movement as a teenager
participated in lunch counter sit-ins in
the early 1960s by the way does lunch
counter sit-ins were incredibly
successful because essentially they
helped shame corporations
into opening up their lunch counters
through actually nongovernmental means
he later became the youngest member of
the big six the colloquial name for the
group of civil rights leader including
MLK who organized the march on
Washington he received all sorts of
bipartisan tribute Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell praised Lewis's
civil rights work talked about the
humbling experience of joining hands
with John as members and and members of
Congress in singing we shall overcome at
a 2008 ceremony honoring his friend dr.
Martin Luther King jr. President Trump
and First Lady Melania Trump
put out a statement via Trump's Twitter
account obviously he and Luis were not
on speaking terms Luis certainly not a
trump in I believe boycotted the
inauguration but Trump put out a
statement saying said and here the news
of civil rights hero John was passing
Melania and I send our prayers to him
and his family vice president Penn's
considered Luis a colleague and a friend
said he was unfailingly kind and that
his quote selflessness and conviction
rendered our nation into a more perfect
union
his example will inspire generations of
Americans and President Obama said that
he quote loved this country so much he
risked his life in his blood so it might
live up to its promise and through the
decades he not only gave all of himself
to the cause of freedom of Justice but
inspired generations that followed to
try to live up to his example he's part
of the shared history that we all have
as Americans and the country is lesser
for the loss of John Lewis that does
bring us to a Fox News poll there's a
Fox News poll out today and this is not
about President Trump this is about our
shared values I have a book coming out
tomorrow called how to destroy America
in three easy steps right now it's
ranked in the top three over at Amazon I
think the reason for that is because
there are a lot of questions about
whether we can hold together as a
country in order for us to hold together
as a country we have to share some
common values those values are the
values of the Declaration of
Independence that all men are created
equal regardless of race we all have
equal rights before the law that we have
rights that pre-exists government the
government was created in order to
protect all of those rights well you see
from the civil rights movement heroes is
that these are folks who are invoking
the promises of the Declaration of
Independence
who are invoking the promissory note is
the language Martin Luther King jr.
invoking the promissory note is the
language of Frederick Douglass
suggesting that those values were not
only useful but eternal and universal
and that the failure of the United
States was to live up to its own values
and the story of American history is the
progress toward the fulfillment of the
values expressed in the Declaration of
Independence indeed what makes the
founders heroes rather than villains is
the fact that they helped the world
progress away from values that stood
against those universal enlightenment
values those values that all men are
created equal that we have Liberty the
pre-exists government but those values
are good the failure of our education
system the failure of our media the
failure of our elites to re-encode hate
this message means that the country is
on the verge of falling apart and that's
what you are seeing in the streets today
what you are seeing is a whole group of
young Americans minority Americans who
have been taught that the American Dream
is actually a lie the 16:19 project
which is a pseudo history dedicated to
the proposition that America is
inherently evil that pseudo history has
become the mainstream history and so
many of our institutions and you can see
the gaps in terms of age and race on
these questions I mean listen you can
understand why if you're a black
American you looked in American history
which is replete with Jim Crow and and
slavery you would look at America's
founders skeptically but that's missing
the story the story is that the founding
fathers moved America away from a system
of slavery and toward a system of
freedom and it was indeed the civil
rights leaders who saw in the promises
of the Declaration the lever by which
they could move the country forward away
from the brutality of bigotry and toward
tolerance the story of America is the
story of 1776 it is not the story of
1619 but that's not the story that's
been promulgated to America's young
people and it's not the story that's
been promulgated to black Americans and
Hispanic Americans particularly by these
poll numbers maybe and that's that's a
problem it's not a problem black
Americans or Hispanic Americans or young
people it's a problem with our system
that has failed to teach people the
truth about American history and about
American values because conservatives
abandoned the institutional fight and
instead went toward the political
because too many Americans who have a
traditionally unionist view as I call it
in my book have a traditionally unionist
via meaning we want to hold together
over our history and our
aasif II and our culture they abandoned
the halls of Education they abandon the
halls of media the halls of Hollywood
and instead they focused in on winning
political victories as sort of a
last-gasp attempt to stop the march of
the cultural left and that's been a
failure you can look at these numbers so
here is the question according to a Fox
News poll that is out today in general
do you believe the founders of our
country are better described as villains
or heroes total 15% of Americans believe
that the founders were villains 63%
believed that the founders were heroes
15% said it depends seven percent said
they don't know that means fully almost
four in 10 americans don't know or
disagree that the founders were heroes
the founders were heroes were they
flawed absolutely did they commit acts
of great evil that were commonplace at
the time by the way yes absolutely does
that mean that the evil is minimized no
what does it mean it means that when we
look at the contributions of the
founders we are now looking at them as
slaveholders were looking at the values
they espoused that led to the rise of
the greatest most free most tolerant
most prosperous nation in the history of
the world the story of the founding
fathers is not truly the story of
slavery or evil the story of the
founding fathers is the Declaration of
Independence slavery and evil are part
of that because that's a universal human
sin but to look at America and see just
the bad which is the purpose of so many
of the disintegration us in our society
is to miss read the history yes we
should obviously look at the sins the
evils of American history as a
corrective to a completely whitewashed
version of American history but the evil
does not overcome the good the story of
humanity the world over is human sin and
human flaw and human evil the story of
the American Revolution is the story of
putting in place a system that would
gradually over time vitiated those sins
that's the story that needs to be told
so that poll number that shows 63% of
Americans think the founders were heroes
as opposed to 37% who either don't know
or don't think that they were heroes
it's pretty devastating poll means that
a very close majority actually believed
in the foundations of the country and
when you look at the demographic
breakdown it's even worse 39% of black
Americans believe that the founders were
villains only 31% believe that the
founders were heroes
sixteen percent said it depends fourteen
percent said they don't know if a
plurality of black Americans believe
that the founders were villains that's
gonna be a problem for the future of the
country because if the founders were
villains then the values that they
espoused are villainous values and this
is the perspective of the Nicole Hannah
Joneses of the world this is the
perspective of the Robins II Angelo's of
the world that America's system is in
and of itself cruel and racist and
vicious 26% of Hispanic Americans
believe the founders were villains
forty-four percent believed they were
heroes twenty-one percent say that it
depends eight percent say they don't
know so blacks and Hispanics a plurality
at least well actually a pure majority
refused to say that the founders were
heroes by the way this holds true for
young Americans as well and this is not
just a racial thing this is this is a
failure of our educational system if you
look at Americans who are under the age
of forty five fifty percent say heroes
23 percent say villains but if you look
at under the age of 30 it gets worse
under the age of 30 only 31 31 percent
of Americans under the age of 30 believe
that the founders were villains only 39
percent say the founders were heroes
which means over 6 and 10 young
Americans under the age of 30 over 6 in
10 believe that the founders were not
heroes which is just devastating for the
future of the country again if you're
gonna have a country any country not
just America any country that holds
together has to share a common set of
values they have to share a common
history that's share a common culture
now the values the history and the
culture of the United States are
embedded respectively in the Declaration
of Independence in the Constitution in
our cultural institutions institutions
like church our education system our
media right values of entrepreneurial
ISM values of virtue and in the common
history and when we look at our history
again we have to acknowledge all the
sins we have to acknowledge all the
evils but we have to recognize an
American history is a glorious thing it
is a glorious story of overcoming those
sins of human nature our inability to
teach young people this our inability to
teach that the promise has been extended
to minorities and that the story of
America is the flaws of human beings
failing to understand the reality and
the truth of the founding principle and
then the gradual realization of that
principle that failure has deep and
abiding consequences and you can see
those consequences in the streets today
as violence continues as the country
overwhelmingly feels like it is falling
apart and that that feels right it feels
like it's fine but a lot people gonna
blame Trump for the following a part of
the country that is not right these are
long-term trends they've been I'd say
catalyzed by president Trump's election
because there was a feeling among
members of the left that they've
captured the Democratic Party and that
they could gradually move the Democratic
Party toward their goal which was the
dissolution of the system over time then
they would never lose again and then
when President Trump won it was like a
shock to the system they couldn't take
it and so that has catalyzed so much of
the opposition and so much of the rage
that we are seeing right now so what
does that mean it means that it from
losses then presumably a lot of the rage
and opposition will be integrated back
into the Democratic Party as opposed to
being sort of outside the system more
generally but it doesn't mean that the
overall threats in the American system
is gone it just means that it goes back
underground into the halls of the
Democratic Party where the battle really
rages race I was during the Obama
administration when the sort of roots of
the aoc squad versus the the Nancy
Pelosi quote/unquote traditionalist
started to build right that broke out
into the open after from selection they
could see that it was building a lot
earlier than that I mean the Ferguson
riots were happening during Barack
Obama's presidency so obviously there
was this this outraged belief by a huge
number of Americans that America was
endemic Lieb wrong and bad and evil they
may have used the Democratic Party as a
vehicle for expressing those values in
terms of politics but they've been
generally unsatisfied with that over
time which is why again there was so
much I think resistance to Hillary
Clinton is a nominee that's why Bernie
Sanders was so successful despite the
fact that he's an octogenarian communist
or maybe because of the fact that he's
an octogenarian communist bottom line is
this if we don't rien que tout values
America is gonna fail if we do not react
locate the values of America's Founding
America is going to fail and it's
there's no excuse for that
we are the freest most prosperous most
tolerant country in the history of the
world the fact that that may not have
been true historically it is certainly
true now the idea that America ought to
be living on razor's edge at this point
in time is patently
except for the fact that we have
undermined all of the values that we
share now I don't mean for that to be a
book pitch but essentially is should go
check out my book how to destroy America
in three easy steps it comes out
tomorrow it is available over at
amazon.com as well as everywhere else
that you buy books you can go check it
out right now in just a second we're
gonna get to your kovat at 19 updates
first we're home more than usual these
days but it's still hard to keep a close
eye on things more deliveries means more
boxes left unattended more opportunities
for packages to go missing thankfully
there's ring comm I have two separate
friends who have had their mailboxes
robbed in recent weeks because of
ring.com they were able to give the
footage directly to the police were able
to track down the people who are doing
the stealing ring is on a mission to
make neighborhoods safer their home
security products are designed to give
you peace of mind around the clock from
video doorbells and security cameras to
smart security lighting and alarm
systems ring has everything you need to
make sure your family and belongings are
safe and secure anytime anywhere and
with the all new ring video doorbell
three you can keep an even closer eye on
things than ever before ring gives you a
video protection at every corner video
doorbells let you answer the door and
check in on your home anytime keep an
eye on your doorstep speak to delivery
people when you can't come to the door
without door security cameras you can
check in on every part of your house
never miss a moment smart lighting
brightens up blind spots makes sure you
always come home to a brightly lit house
get a special offer on the ring welcome
kit when you go to ring calm / been that
welcome kit includes the ring video
doorbell 3 and the chime pro it's all
you need to start building custom
security for your home today just go to
ring comm / button that is our ing comm
/ pin and get a special offer on that
ring and welcome can't we rely on it in
my home you should to go ring calm / man
that is ring.com / Ben
okay so Mon kovin 19 Cova 19 continues
to spread almost unchecked throughout
the country at this point it is not
restricted to red states it is happening
pretty much everywhere you can look at
the uptick in cases across the country
there's an uptick in places like Ohio
there's an uptick in places like Montana
there's an uptick in places like
Maryland which is a blue state with a
red governor there's an uptick in
Colorado now there's an uptick in Puerto
Rico there's an uptick in Rhode Island
right you're seeing a rise in cases that
is happening essentially across the
country you're also seeing a sort of
flattening out in in the death rate at
least at this point what we have seen on
at ante level is the
we're hovering around a thousand deaths
today someone from 800 to a thousand
deaths a day over the last few days none
of which is good right mean these are
all bad numbers obviously but what it
does suggest is maybe we're starting to
see a flattening out we're certainly
starting to see a flattening out in
terms of the hospitalization rate in
places like Arizona and Texas unclear
whether that is happening in Florida
although their early indicators that may
be happening in Florida the real issue
here is I discussed last week is there
may not be any great answers here now I
know the media want to promulgate this
notion that there are basically two
answers to this and two answers only one
is mandatory masking masking and the
second is lockdowns media law of the
lactams I mean they really love lock
downs and the idea behind this is that
if you want to prevent the spread of the
disease you have to keep people cooped
up in their homes now the problem is
that that's not national solution and we
all know this this is not something that
can last interminably the Europeans know
this Israelis know this everyone all
over the world is trying to figure out
how they can reopen and when they can
reopen and how much spread they can
allow when they do reopen the lock downs
were never meant to crush the curve and
this is a new phrase remember it was
flatten the curve before right you
remember flatten the curve they flatten
the curve was all sorts of fun tours 15
days to stop the spread and you had
giant spike and then you had the lesser
spike and I'm just gonna draw the quick
chart for you right here
you can see this line here represented
medical capacity and then saw the big
big wave over here and this is the one
you wanted to avoid right because
everything that was in this shaded area
was going to be excess death the medical
system was not going to be able to
integrate these folks and these people
were going to die I think what we were
looking for instead was a broader longer
curve right the brighter longer curve
that meant there were still give me a
lot of cases but it also meant that
fewer people were going to die and now
what's been weird about this is now we
are talking about crushing the curve so
the idea about crushing the curve is
that in order to prevent all
transmission of the disease forever we
should just stay home forever and now
that has never been a solution that's
never been a solution the the full
lockdown policy has not been a solution
so the real question is are we
threatening the system and if we are
threatening the system then what you're
gonna have to have are sort of
intermittent letting people out and
putting people back in and this is what
we're again this is nothing new this is
what the quote-unquote experts were
saying at the very beginning they were
saying they're gonna be alternating
policies of sort of quasi lockdown and
half lockdown and
and we're gonna have to vary it based on
County this is what the experts were
saying and then when that happens the
entire media suggests oh my god we're
all gonna die oh my god we're doing it
wrong
you know who's really doing it wrong
those red states and and then you look
at the numbers and what you see is that
blue states are getting hit too
Colorado's getting hit too California is
getting smoked right now I live in LA
County LA County is looking at another
lockdown right now not just another
lockdown they're looking at a stuffed
full stay at home order hey Eric
Garcetti says the corona virus is
spreading in the city to the point where
a new stay-at-home order might have to
be issued
he said we're on the brink of that he
said this on CNN he declined to be more
specific he said we have to be surgical
rather than a cleaver that would just
shut everything down
he said he agreed earlier restrictions
had been relaxed to quickly
he said mayor's often have no control
over what reopens up and what doesn't
that's either at a state or a county
level but he added it's not just about
what's open and closed it's also about
what we do individually okay let's be
real about this la never opened okay
I've been here la did not open hey there
was a mild mild reopening and then it
sort of clamped shut again so the notion
that lock downs are the answer to this
thing in the long term Reve in the mid
term is just not right meanwhile the
sort of red blue gap that supposedly
existed it doesn't really exist you're
seeing an uptick in cases in places like
Colorado you're not seeing it to the
extent that you've seen it in places
like Florida or Texas but that's because
it's not as hot in Colorado right now
but you are setting up ticking Colorado
that's because Colorado opened at the
same time as Georgia one of the reasons
that you've seen an uptick across the
south is because the hotter it gets by
the way I expect that because there's
been a heat wave in places like
Washington DC you'll see an uptick there
too because of the heat people are being
driven inside two air-conditioned closed
areas and this means that you're seeing
a spike in cases none of this should be
surprising it's not supremely surprising
but again we moved from flatten the
curve to avoid spiking over the
healthcare capacity to crush the curve
which supposedly means that you're just
supposed to stay home forever well
that's not going to work nope like this
notion that this was ever going to be a
consistent policy that as we reopen
gradually there would be no setbacks
along the way I don't know where this
came from I seriously don't know where
it came from so the NIH director
yesterday he said well the big problem
here is dr. Francis Collins is that
states jumped over the CDC
recommendations they
moved too fast here or alternatively
whenever you let people out of home
confinement there's going to be a spread
in cases I literally said this every day
for months that the only purpose here
was to allow us some time to buy us some
time
right allow the medical system to get
better at this and good news the medical
system did get better at this the rate
of IC use 2 hospitalizations is down the
rate of deaths to IC use is down younger
people are getting this which you don't
want anybody getting this but younger
people getting it is a lot better than
older people getting it and even when
people are getting it we now have better
treatments we know things we didn't know
at the very beginning
simple things like flipping people onto
their stomach can sometimes help prevent
putting them on a ventilator but here
was the NIH director saying the big
problem is that states jumped over CDC
recommendations listen when you're a
government actor I understand the
incentive structure the incentive
structure is to always say people who
aren't cautious enough and that's why
all this happened here's the reality
what happened here was by all indicators
fairly inevitable it has happened in
every single state every single one
without regard to politics in the only
states that have not seen a major uptick
are states where there are no people
ok Alaska has not seen an uptick because
there were no people Maine has not seen
a significant uptick because there are
no people Wyoming has not seen a
significant uptick because there are no
people where there are lots of people
there is lots of spread and when you
reopen there's gonna be a little more
spread and that was never the question
again the question was not are people
going to get it the question was is it
gonna swamp the healthcare system so far
we've seen no indicators that the
healthcare system has been completely
swamped in fact as we've said
hospitalization rates are going down
ICU rates are going down death rates
have been going down since their peak
when we talk about how Texas and Florida
they're the new New York no they're not
even close to the new New York New York
was losing like a thousand people a day
Texas and Florida as bad as they've been
are losing like 130 hundred forty people
a day that's terrible that is not New
York rates anyway here's the NIH
director saying the big problem here is
that people opened up too early even
though by the way many of these states
opened up in early May and we didn't see
a spike in terms of case rate until like
mid June like approximately two weeks
after those mass protests in the streets
remember those here's the CIA here is
the the NIH director we basically did a
good job in New York and New Jersey and
Connecticut with that terrible crisis
that happened and took many lives and if
you look to see what
happening now in those areas they came
down very close to zero but meanwhile
the rest of the country perhaps
imagining this was just a New York
problem kind of went about their
business didn't really pay that much
attention to CDC's recommendations about
the phases necessary to open up safely
and jumped over some of those hoops and
people started congregating and not
wearing masks and feeling like it's over
and maybe summer it'll all go away and
now here we are okay I frankly cannot
believe that America's public officials
are talking on to New York it is
unbelievable to me it's like talking up
Italy how in the world are you talking
up the area of the country they got
smoked New Jersey and New York and
Connecticut got brutalized approximately
37 percent of all deaths in the United
States from cover 19 happen though
threes those three states alone they
represent like six percent of the
American population that is nuts
to talk up those states look at what
they did in New York New Jersey
Connecticut they really handled their
bleep did they though by the way this is
the exact same thing that Anthony found
she said and then you asked me to trust
the experts listen I'm happy to listen
to the experts when they say blatant
bullsh let me say blatant bullcrap I men
have a tough time believing them okay
again the death rates per million the
states with the worst death rates per
million are in order New Jersey New York
Connecticut followed by Massachusetts
Rhode Island and District of Columbia
all of those areas did exactly what the
CDC and the NIH said they should and got
smoked so the idea that they've now
conquered this thing know what happened
in New York and New Jersey the reason
they're not seeing an uptick right now
is because everyone's dead
okay anyway here's Anthony pouchy again
I don't like what's going through his
head that he is that he's praising New
York's response to this I just don't get
it we have a problem we need to admit it
and own it but we've got to do the
things that are very clear that we need
to do to turn this around remembering we
can do it we know that when you do it
properly you bring down those cases
we've done it we've done it in New York
New York got hit worse than anyplace in
the world and they did it correctly they
did it correctly how do they do it
correctly everyone died what what okay
we're gonna get some more of this in a
second you wonder why we can't have
unity why we can't have nice things we
can't have nice things because our
experts are telling us stupid stuff like
that I'm sorry
dumb that's just dumb okay I've been
I've been a foul Qi defender I've been
saying he's doing he's doing the best he
can he's operating off the best info
when you just spill blatant crap into
the public like New York did it right I
don't know what to tell you okay that's
just obviously not true by every
available metric that's not true can
we're gonna get some more of this in
just one second first as we slowly
adjust to the new normal we still need
to be smart about how we do business one
of those things means why are you
wasting time and energy going to the
post office instead head on over to
stamps calm stamps calm it makes things
easier thousands of small business
owners have discovered the benefits of
stamps calm in recent months they've
been able to keep their businesses
running avoid the crowds at the post
office all from their own computers with
stamps calm you can print postage on
demand avoid going to the post office
and you'll save money with discounted
rates you can't even get at the post
office
stamps calm also offers UPS services
with discounts up to 62 percent no
residential surcharges it's a great
service here daily wire there's a reason
we've been using daily using stamps calm
since 2017 no more wasting our time we'd
save ourselves tons of time and tons of
money which is what we like to do here
and our fully functioning Deathstar
stamps.com me a great discounts five
cents off every stamp 62 percent off use
USPS and UPS shipping rates stamped calm
is a no-brainer it saves you time and it
saves you money right now my listeners
get a special offer four week trial plus
free postage and digital scale no long
term commitment just go to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage type in Shapiro that is
stamps.com enter Shapiro at the top of
the homepage click on that microphone
stamps.com you had a four week trial
plus free postage and digital scale no
long-term commitment stamps.com click on
that mic at the top of the home page
type in Shapiro ok so again the media
have come up with this narrative this
narrative is there are two basic
strategies that can be used with regard
to coronavirus one is you lock
everything down or we're gonna yell at
you and two is masking again I am I am
put off by the fact that people who are
promoting lockdowns right now are
simultaneously saying and again that is
Anthony voucher the head of the National
Institute for infectious and allergic
and infectious diseases and the NIH
director both touting New York is an
example of what to do I don't know how
that's possible
I really don't know how that's possible
Anthony Andrew Cuomo Andrew Cuomo he
didn't at the governor of New York he
did not shut down the subways until the
beginning of May
ok didn't
cleanse you can clean them until the
beginning of May take like even
overnight he didn't clean them he was
shipping elders with Kovac back into
nursing homes for months like how how is
that the example of what you were doing
right okay okay so the other angle that
is being used here is that masking is
the be-all end-all that listen I wear a
mask
in fact I insisted everybody in my
immediate vicinity at the office wear a
mask I take this stuff very seriously
the evidence on mask wearing is mixed
okay let's should be frank about this
dr. Scott Ellis had Hoover Institute
from Stanford University he has said the
evidence is mixed the CDC says the
evidence is mixed the whu-oh says the
evidence is mixed now if there is the
the chance that is going to lower the
the rates of transmission than out of an
abundance of caution
I recommend masking okay so I've never
been an opponent of masking I've never
thought it was a grave infringement on
my liberty to ask me to mask up when I
go into a highly crowded area I've
always thought okay seems like a
cautious and well taken step but the
notion that masking is the be-all
end-all and this has simply become the
be-all end-all because Trump refused to
mask I mean really is that but if Trump
had not said anything Trump could come
out early and he had said you know it's
a good idea masking this would not be an
issue but the media we're looking for
points of political polarization now
here's the problem the data do not back
the idea that tons of Americans are
wildly wildly anti masking there are
some Americans who are wildly anti
masking but by and large in the areas
where there are the most cases people
are overwhelmingly masking I pointed
this out on Twitter over the weekend
people went nuts I pointed out that if
you look at them the areas of the
country where their highest levels of
infection those are also the areas where
there are the highest levels of masking
now people on the left immediately
refuse to read my follow-up tweets in
the thread which pointed out that I was
not saying that masks don't stop the
spread of disease I was pointing out
merely that where people are seeing
infections they are masking so the idea
that people are being overwhelmingly
willy-nilly stupid and just going out
were there tons of infections like in
Miami and not wearing masks is really
dumb I was in Florida for a couple of
weeks people were masked up right as
things were happening in Miami everybody
was wearing a mask
okay in LA everyone wears a mask the the
basic idea the media put out there
though is that this is just a failure of
masking now there are a couple of flaws
in this sort of thinking so here
is a poll it was put out by the New York
Times and it shows by percentage how
often people from different places say
they wear a mask when they leave the
house and here's what it shows in the
Philippines 92% of people say that they
always wear masks when they leave the
house always in Mexico which is just
getting smoked right now Mexico's
numbers are awful one of the reasons
that we're seeing a spike in border
counties and there is there's a massive
spike in border counties even the New
York Times has been forced to now pay
attention to this vulnerable border
counties are now being overwhelmed with
new cases the reason for this is because
some people are crossing the border
illegally and because if somebody
crosses the border from highly hit
Mexico into a border town it spreads
more easily in the Rio Grande Valley
more than a third of families according
to the New York Times live in poverty up
to half the residents have no health
insurance including at least a hundred
thousand undocumented people who often
rely on under-resourced community
clinics or emergency rooms for care
places like the southernmost wedge of
Texas are seeing a punishing surge in
infections okay so Mexico is actually
serious problem you seen this in Arizona
as well that Texas in Arizona are
getting hard-hit particularly in the
border counties hey but Mexico go back
to the chart showing the masking rate
Mexico eighty-five percent of people in
Mexico say they always wear a mask when
they leave the house in Spain which got
devastated eighty four percent people
say they wear a mask when they leave the
house so there is this basic idea out
there that masking equals really low
rates of death and then people look at
Hong Kong which by the way is
experiencing another surgeon actually
the the Hong Kong government just
announced that they are going to mandate
masks it's not just voluntary more than
a mandate masks and they're gonna go
back into lock now because Hong Kong has
seen a surge in cases now the surge in
cases in Hong Kong is like 100 cases as
opposed to you know 70,000 in the United
States but for Hong Kong which never
experienced a major hit that's a pretty
MIT like they said basically it's
spreading out of control we can't
contact trace it anymore is what they
were saying over the weekend over in
Hong Kong but you can see the
differential case of Spain their death
per million rates the death per million
rate in Spain per million population is
608 okay which is significantly higher
than that of the United States I believe
we're in the mid 400s death per million
rate okay 84% of the population of Spain
says they mask
83% of the population in Hong Kong says
they mask the Hong Kong death rate is 2
per 1 million 2
okay so there's a pretty wild
differential there so if you're looking
at independent variables masking doesn't
seem to be the most obvious independent
variable Italy right where everybody got
wiped out 83% of the population says
they mask Germany where they really
didn't get very hard hit 63% of the
population says that they mask the
United States by the way 59% of
Americans say they mask every time they
go out of the house now
this is all self-reported so who knows
if it's true self reporting social
science data is usually the worst but
59% of Americans say they always mask as
opposed to 14% who say they never mask
and now let's look at some of the other
countries on this list
4% of people in Norway say they always
mask 0% ok effectively 0% in Denmark
Finland and Sweden say they mask when
they go out of the house 9% in the
Netherlands 10% in Australia 19% in the
UK 35% in Canada so I keep her in Canada
did this right Canada's doing it right
okay but Canada is not asking so what's
the deal France 54% sent a mask as
opposed to 59% in the United States and
yet what we keep hearing is masking
masking masking again this is mostly
because President Trump has not been so
active on the masking front which again
I I think out of an abundance of caution
you mask but the the very weird notion
that America is not masking like there's
not a lot of data to demonstrate this
okay I'm looking at the map right now
from the New York Times that shows how
often do you wear a mask in public when
you expect to be within six feet of
another person in all of the hotspots
the numbers are in excess of 80 percent
of people well it's certainly an excess
of 75% some people say that they always
wear a mask when they are with other
people and nearly everyone else is
frequently very few people say rarely or
never okay but the merit of the media is
that there are only two things that can
shut this down lockdown which is never
going to be a long-term solution and
masking which most people in America are
adopting and yet the thing is still
spreading why well there are a few
reasons there are a few reasons one
community spread never stopped America
is a very big country and because
America is a very big very populous
country it looks a lot more in urban
areas like Italy or New York than it
does like Vermont okay that's number one
or like Maine number two the strain
that's hit the United States is the
European strain on the Asian strain so
comparing what's happening in Vietnam
Hong Kong or Taiwan to what's happening
in the United States not actually
accurate it's a different strain the
Chinese virus went to Europe there it
mutated it became about ten times as
transmissible and that's what's been
hitting the United States now the good
news is it seems like it was a lot less
deadly than the version that was hitting
Asia the bad news is that it's less
deadly and more transmissible you can
still end up with a higher number of
absolute deaths but the way the media
are pitching this is that the United
States is blowing this there's a long
article in The Washington Post today
about how the United States is blowing
this and apparently they say we came out
too early and we didn't wear masks again
we are masking better than most European
countries the European countries that
are masking better than we are have a
higher death rate in many cases and when
it comes and these are just pure
statistical facts we are testing more
than any other country by a huge margin
an enormous margin so let me talk about
the number of sheer cases being detected
president Trump would be wrong if he
suggests that the tests themselves are
basically the reason why we see
skyrocket in cases we see skyrocket in
cases because there are skyrocketing
cases but those he is right when he says
that we are seeing numbers like actual
confirmed numbers because we are doing
more testing that is true obviously
again that doesn't mean that the spread
is false it just means that we are
seeing the spread more clearly than a
lot of other countries we're doing more
testing we opened up at the same times a
lot of European countries we are
handling this pretty well in the
hospitals and mask-wearing is generally
being adopted but the media's narrative
is that we are uniquely defenseless we
blew this in a way nobody else blew this
here was Chuck Todd yesterday suggesting
the United States is uniquely
defenseless against the virus again I'm
looking at the death rates per million
okay this is from world ah meters I'm
looking at death rates per million and
the death rates per million across the
world the United States is not number
one the United States currently ranks
number ten after
Belgium San Marino Andorra UK Spain
Italy Sweden France and Chile he said
the United States ranks number 10 Brazil
is close on our heels and number 12 the
Netherlands is at number 13 Mexico is
close hundred heels at number 16 the
United States is not in fact uniquely
defenseless against the spread the
United States is struggling with it just
like pretty much everywhere else that
had communities spread without heavy
testing and tracing at the very
beginning
I think we should actually distinguish
between nations that never got hit hard
right they didn't have a key number of
early cases and got on it early and
Nations worded already spread so widely
that was community spread before you
could even do testing and tracing anyway
here is Chuck Todd pushing this notion
that America has handled this uniquely
badly when again the evidence does not
suggest that this is true how did this
happen we are the richest country in
human history with an unmatched medical
infrastructure and a literate educated
populace yet today we stand uniquely
helpless among industrialized countries
in the fight against kovat 19 a world
that once looked up to us to do the
impossible
now averts his eyes over our failure to
do the possible okay again I'm just
wondering what he thinks the possible
looks like when we have locked down
virtually every part of the country for
long periods of time and most people are
asking the National mask mandate from
the Congress I'd like to see Nancy
Pelosi promote it do it and let's see if
we can get away with this
constitutionally its most people are
adopting smart behaviors just that by
the way before lockdown people lockdown
okay people are generally acting in
self-interested fashion the lock downs
helped slow the spread which is what
they were supposed to do they were never
the full-on answer but this is the
narrative the narrative is that the
United States has blown it in every way
except for the democratic areas which
have done incredibly well like New York
New Jersey and Connecticut which is just
a joke okay that is it that is not
correct how this thing got political as
opposed to everybody is struggling with
the right answers in an unprecedented
time I think it's pretty obvious that
all we are seeing right now with kovat
is just sort of the final iteration of a
country's dissolution it seems like that
is that is really what is happening here
hopefully with the help of God this is
not you know the final period of the
American epic I don't think it is but it
certainly feels that way when we can't
even get our bleep together on
recognizing decent intent for most
people when it comes to trying to handle
a global pandemic which by the way is
again rising in many areas that are not
the United States okay in just a second
when I get to President Rumpy did an
interview with chris wallace who's much
ballyhooed we'll talk about it in just a
second first my new book as I've
mentioned how to destroy America in
three easy steps it goes on stay on sale
tomorrow Tuesday July 21st 6:00 p.m.
Eastern 3 p.m. Pacific we will be doing
a virtual live signing event on the day
of release with your purchase of a
signed copy you can write in a question
could be read and answered as I sign
your book live on the air could be lucky
you you can pre-order your signed copy
and write in your question at daily
wire.com /ban the book covers two
fundamentally different visions of
America that are now on the table one
vision is unifying vision I've been
talking about the unionist vision where
we look at our shared philosophy culture
and history we agree on it and we move
forward together
the other disintegrates our country in
the name of fundamental change
narratives like robin D'Angelo's white
fragility or the new york times 1619
project these are classic examples of
the disintegration of
this integrationist look at canceled
culture as a way to Club everyone in
submission and to use sheer power
politics to destroy the foundations upon
which we stand
how destroy America in three easy steps
to details how the disintegration aswer
love you has gained so much cultural
ground so quickly it offers a
penetrating view of our culture and it
tells us where to go from here and how
we can fight back again that's daily
wire.com / Ben so order your signed copy
today join my live signing on Tuesday
July 21st also 2020 has been an
unbelievably insane year remember that
time Trump was in Beach that happened
this year and the leftist media they are
not helping obviously when it comes to
everything from Cova to racial politics
when you can't get the real story you
have to go outside the narrative and get
the facts so if you're a political
junkie set on getting both sides of the
story
get a reader's past today from daily
wire calm you'll get access to exclusive
op-eds from us your podcast hosts as
well as guest writers in depth analysis
from our daily where reporters on top of
our regular breaking news you can check
out my latest piece 5 reasons why the
media is narrative about how we blew
Kobe 19 actually not correct his
membership tier is already a bargain at
3 bucks a month if you join today get
your first month for 99 cents you also
get access to a mobile app and you
receive push notifications for breaking
news and special content as well as join
the community of daily where members are
actively commenting and discussing our
content with each other that's mobile
add free access to all of the daily wire
news exclusive op-eds all of our
podcasts on our mobile app all for the
low price of $1 and best of all your
dollars are getting you the news you
need without the left to spin so head on
over to daily wire.com slash subscribe
and join today you're listening to the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
all righty so all of this kind of chaos
on kovat at 19 has led to people
basically declaring themselves virtuous
for saying that they're not gonna go
back to work there's a piece in the new
york times snake hope i won't return to
the classroom and you shouldn't ask me
to buy Rebecca Martinson and I looked at
Miss Martinson she appears to be I it's
hard to judge people's appearances she
appears to be in her 40s probably she
does not look like she's in her 60s or
70s which means that she's at higher
risk of Kogut but she's not a severe
risk of death from coven she says that
she doesn't want to go back to work
she's a public schoolteacher she says
everyday when I walk into work as a
public schoolteacher I'm prepared to
take a bullet to save a child in the age
of school shootings that's what the job
requires but asking me to return to the
classroom amid a pandemic and expose
myself and my family to cover 19 is like
asking me to take that bullet home to my
own family I won't do it and you
shouldn't want me to she became an
educator after career as a nurse I teach
medical science and introduction to
nursing to eleventh and twelfth graders
at a regional skill center that serves
students from 22 different high schools
in 13 different school districts she
says that her school district in school
haven't ruled out asking us to return to
in-person teaching in the fall
nothing I've heard reassures me I can
safely teach in person so a couple of
things one we have essential workers and
I mean people who are like grocery
stores who've been working for months
they never stopped working our public
school teachers less essential then the
workers who are staffing the grocery
stores I've been told the public
education is the number one most
essential business in America which is
why we should be spending oils and
oodles of cash on it so which is it is
it essential or is it non-essential we
know the risk to kids is essentially
minimal from kovin 19 why is it that we
can't try the solution proposed by my
friend jean pied it's a commentary
magazine bring the kids back to school
have the teacher Skype in if you're so
worried or why not have younger teachers
but this this notion that you are
essentially protected from disease when
you go to school as a teacher listen
life is filled with risks that does not
mean that we shouldn't take measures to
try and protect our teachers I know a
lot of private schools looking to open
they want to protect their teachers too
and you know what they're doing
there they're taking measures to do
exactly that I assume that they would do
the same thing in the school district
that this woman teaches at but it's hard
to declare yourself an essential worker
while saying you're less essential than
the people who work at the grocery
stores who by the way been asked to go
into work and who are disproportionately
young the
this is not about the kids right it's
not it's just not about the kid and you
know it's gonna happen here there's
gonna be a vast increase in home
schooling as there has been over the
last year or so she suggests distance
learning systems learning has been a
giant fail for public schools
I believe the statistic was in LAUSD 40%
of students never opened a computer when
they got home the gaps that are going to
emerge the class gaps here are gonna be
incredible people like me I can afford
to be and to spend time at home my wife
can spend time at home my kids
grandparents my parents can spend time
with my kids at home
my daughter has has thrived in this
homeschooling period she went from being
a kindergartner reading at first grade
level to a kindergartner reading at
third grade level during this period how
many people is that true of who are
already struggling with the finances you
want to exacerbate class conflict you
want to exacerbate income inequality
make sure that people can't go to school
and so this narrative has some fairly
significant consequences also it happens
to be anti-scientific
Europe has reopened at schools the
schools have not been the main vector of
spread particularly for younger kids
there's some evidence that junior high
kids are spreading this thing but that
evidence is is still not as rich as you
would like
certainly for young kids the idea that
young kids are supposed to stay out of
school is kind of crazy it's kind of
crazy
hey meanwhile President Trump did an
interview on Fox News with Chris Wallace
the media were all over it because Chris
Wallace basically fact-check Trump in
real time there's only one problem half
the fact checks Chris Wallace actually
said I'm not quite correct Trump called
him on then he called Trump on some of
them and it was a particularly horrible
showing by Trump but it did show that
that Trump's fluency with the fact is
not all that high it also shows some of
the difficulties he's gonna have with
Joe Biden mainly because he's trying to
draw a troop a two-prong narrative
against Joe Biden Pro number one is that
Joe Biden is senile and old and doesn't
have it together and and then prong
number two is that Joe Biden is a true
threat to the country now the way that
you could do this is you could say Joe
Biden is so senile and so crazy that his
vice presidents actually gonna be
President you kind of have to wait until
he selects a VP if Joe Biden were to
select a Camilla Harris then you just
attack combo Harris right you see Joe
Biden is not the president Kamala Harris
is the president that would be the line
of attack I think that that maybe Trump
is waiting for here but in in the
meantime you have this bizarre dual
message where Joe Biden is
simultaneously deeply unthreatening
because he's not alive and
simultaneously SuperDuper threatening
cuz he's a socialist secretly
so here's President Trump - Chris
Wallace talking about Biden doing an
interview like this one you know again
this is I don't know there's gonna be a
particularly successful attack by the
president here let him come out of his
basement go around
I'll make four or five speeches a day
I'll be interviewed by you I'll be
interviewed by the worst killers that
hate Mike my guts they hate my guts
there's nothing they can ask me that I
won't give them a proper answer - some
people will like it some people won't
like I agree with that but look you
answer the little fight and sit through
an interview like this he'll be on the
ground crying for mommy he'll say mommy
mommy please take me home
but we've asked him for an interview sir
he can't do an interview he's
incompetent okay but I mean there's
truth to this there is truth to this but
simultaneously that's actually not the
biggest problem for Trump meaning and
for Biden I mean it mean that Biden
being a not alive person has I've been
saying for months is actually one of his
great assets Trump is what the the kovat
is really hampered Trump's ability to
campaign just on a political level put
aside his reaction to Cova Trump's
ability to campaign has really been
stifled here Trump's main pitch in 2016
one of them was he's a high-energy dude
right Hillary Clinton was stumbling into
vans and Donald Trump same age was
running around the country taking jets
to seven different places doing these
rallies demonstrating high levels of
energy he's boxed in he can't do rallies
right now and that's really hurting him
in a fairly major way it doesn't help
when the president starts talking about
his own cognitive facility or faculty he
says that Chris Wall he tells Chris
Wallace he passed a cognitive test
easily and Chris Wallace is like right
but that cognitive test is can you
identify an elephant that's not the
hardest task no but the last picture and
it's an Eleanor not again you see that's
all misrepresentation that's what it was
on the web so a misrepresentation
because yes the first few questions are
easy but I'll bet you couldn't even
answer the last five questions I'll bet
you couldn't they get very hard the last
five well one of them ones come back
from a hundred by seven and let me tell
you now if you couldn't answer you
couldn't answer all right what's the
question many of the questions I'd get
you the test I'd like to give it but I
guarantee you the Joe Biden could not
answer those questions you and I
answered all 35 questions correctly
okay I'm sorry that's not anywhere I'm
sorry that's just not going anywhere
this is not it's a cognitive test guys
cognitive test
not the same things like the SAT this
wasn't the LSAT he was taking her it
wasn't thing the medical boards and
cognitive tests is basically does her
brain function it is not I mean Chris
Wallace is not wrong on this what Chris
Wallace is wrong is there are certain
times here where Wallace just repeated
stuff that wasn't true so for example
Wallace was confronting Trump on Kovac
mortality rates and Wallace was
suggesting the United States is one of
the worst in the world is dealing with
this and Trump was like no or not and
Trump is actually right here we have the
seventh highest mortality rate in the
world our mortality rate is higher than
Brazil it's higher than Russia and the
European Union has us on a travel ban
yeah I think what we'll do well we have
never done a travel ban to Chris I
closed them off if you remember I was
the one that did the European Union very
early but when you talk about mortality
rates I think it's the opposite I think
we have one of the lowest mortality
rates alert week well we had 900 deaths
on a single day we will take this number
one low mortality rate I hope you showed
the center because it shows what fake
news is all of it okay and Trump is
right about this again I read you the
stats a little bit earlier so Wallace
actually had it wrong here so the media
we're treating it as though Trump got
everything wrong here that is not
correct well it's got a bunch of things
wrong here okay another example of this
Wallace C Wallace and Trump one added
about whether Trump about whether Biden
has threatened to defund the police and
this really rests and it hinges on the
question of what do you mean by defund
the police so the left has played a game
with defund the police on the one hand
you have some people who are like defund
the police means completely defund the
police no more police it's true Biden
said I'm not the funding the police then
there's defund the police as in shift
funding away from the cops and towards
social workers and Biden basically
embraced that I guess it just as a
predicate here is a flashback Joe Biden
saying he supports redirecting money
from police and then suggests that the
police have in some cases become the
enemy instead of sending two police
officers with deadly weapons to that
Wendy's drive-thru in Atlanta we could
have sent a wellness counselor and a tow
truck and then raise Hart Brooks would
still be alive today and his three
daughters would still have their daddy
are you open to that kind of reform yes
I propose that kind of reform
surplus military equipment for law
enforcement they don't need that a last
thing you need is an up-armored hmmwv
coming into a neighborhood just like the
military invading they don't know
anybody to become
the enemies are supposed to protecting
these people so my generic point is that
we agree that we can redirect some of
the funding yes absolutely
okay we were told that that's exactly
what do you fund the police means by the
experts right there were full articles
in The Washington Post in York Times
suggesting that defund the police means
shifting the funding which Joe Biden
embraced here is Chris Wallace telling
Trump
full-scale that Joe Biden does not want
to defund the police liberal Democrats
have been running cities in this country
for decades poorly well why is it so bad
right now they've run him poorly it was
always bad but now it's gotten totally
out of control and it's really because
they wanted to fund the police and Biden
once the fun defogger he does not look
he signed a charter with Bernie Sanders
I will get that one just like I was
right in the mortality rate did you read
the chart of the heat and because I do
nothing about the funding oh really it
says abolish it says the let's go
all right give me the Charter please
you've got to start studying for these
okay he's not right about the platform
he is right though that the Joe Biden
has suggested before that he wants to
shift funding away from police right so
then the media are playing this is look
at Chris Wallace really grilling Trump
Trump did okay during the interview he
related this wasn't a bad interview for
Trump the big problem for Trump is that
until Joe Biden appoints a VP it's gonna
be difficult for Joe Biden to be
attacked as sort of a threat to the
Republic and the other attack that Joe
Biden is kind of seen out like we all
know man that's that's not really much
of an attack already
so we'll be back here a little bit later
today with two additional hours of
content in the meantime go out and
purchase a copy of my book how to
destroy America in three easy steps
surging up the bestseller charts right
now it is out to tomorrow pre-order it
now and be one of the first to read it
otherwise you'll see you here later
today or tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the bench Bureau Show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas executive producer Jeremy
boring supervising producer Mathis
Glover and Robert Stirling assistant
director pavel vie dowse key technical
producer Austin Stevens playback and
media operated by Nick Sheehan associate
producer Katie Swinton edited by Adam sy
events audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mina
hair and makeup is by Anika Geneva the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20/20
Konya is back in the presidential race
Trump gives conservatives a lesson on
political power and churches burn around
the West
check it out on a Michael Knowles show
[Music]
you